there are three politicians that are now
calling for the current administration
to not
reappoint jerome powell as a federal
reserve chair what does that mean the
federal reserve chair is not an elected
official it's an appointed official so
we elect politicians into positions of
power they then have the opportunity for
certain
places of influence in the government uh
or in organizations to appoint people to
those seats so we don't get to elect
everyone but we do get elect uh the
politicians and so one of those seats is
obviously the chairman of the federal
reserve jerome powell was appointed back
in 2017 by president donald trump uh and
it is a four-year appointment so when
you get appointed basically you're
signing up for a four-year uh kind of
job stint and then at the end of your
job stint of the first four years uh you
can get reappointed if the president is
the same and you've done a good job
you're likely to get reappointed
sometimes if you've done a good job and
the presidential administration has
changed you may not get reappointed and
then obviously if you did a bad job
in the eyes of those making the
appointment decisions you could also get
fired as well
so
when you think about this it is normal
for this conversation to come up when we
get towards the end so 2017 we're in
2021 now um the term actually expires in
february uh of of this upcoming year and
so far president joe biden uh his white
house or his administration has not said
whether they are going to reappoint uh
jerome powell or not now i want to read
uh just a sentence or two from the full
statement from these three politicians
one is uh aoc uh the second is rashida
toleb i believe i pronounce it and
ayanna presley are the three politicians
and it says quote as news of the
possible reappointment of federal
reserve chair jerome powell circulates
we urge president biden to reimagine a
federal reserve focused on eliminating
climate risk and advancing racial and
economic justice now when you think
about this
it is pretty interesting because what
they're talking about explicitly is
eliminating climate risk and advancing
racial and economic justice
and so when you
ask yourself well what is the job of the
federal reserve right what is that job
uh we can go to federalreserve.gov
and this is exactly i'm just going to
read you word to word what they say what
is the purpose of the federal reserve
system the federal reserve system often
referred to as the federal reserve
simply the fed is the central bank of
the united states it was created by the
congress to provide the nation with a
safer more flexible and more stable
monetary and financial system the
federal reserve was created on december
23 1913 when president woodrow wilson
signed the federal reserve act into law
today the federal reserve's
responsibilities fall into four general
areas those four areas are the following
one conducting the nation's monetary
policy by influencing money money and
credit conditions in the economy in
pursuit of full employment and stable
prices first category of the federal
reserve's role is to pursue full
employment and stable prices
second supervising and regulating banks
and other important financial
institutions to ensure the safety and
soundness of the nation's banking and
financial system and to protect the
credit rights of consumers so the second
thing is to regulate the banks to create
that safety and soundness of the banking
and financial system the third thing is
maintaining the stability of the
financial system and containing systemic
risk that may arise in financial markets
so
systemic risk eliminate and contain uh
any of those risks the fourth thing
providing certain financial services to
the us government u.s financial
institutions and foreign official
institutions and playing a major role in
operating and overseeing the nation's
payment systems okay this is interesting
there's four things that the federal
reserve is focused on or four general
areas the first conducting the monetary
policy with the pursuit of full
employment and stable prices that's one
two is supervising and regulating banks
with a goal of ensuring safety and
soundness of the nation's banking and
financial system okay that sounds that
makes sense three maintaining the
stability of the financial system and
containing containing systemic risk
makes sense four providing certain
financial services to the us government
and other types of organizations
and operating and overseeing the
nation's payment systems got it all that
makes sense to me let's go back to the
statement from these three politicians
they want to reimagine a federal reserve
focused on eliminating climate risk and
advancing racial and economic justice
when you compare what these politicians
are asking versus the
directive the mandate of the federal
reserve they don't match now again
that's not to say that uh eliminating
climate risk and advancing racial and
economic justice is important or not
important it's just that's not the job
of the federal reserve the federal
reserve's job is in the four areas that
we just discussed and so i am incredibly
critical of the monetary policy
decisions i get made uh many times i'm
incredibly uh critical
in terms of the way that we are shared
information um in terms of inflation and
other monetary impact uh and also a
fiscal policy
but at the same time i think it's
important for
critics to also be intellectually honest
and say hey
there are things to critique but there's
also things that we must not uh allow to
enter into the conversation uh that
don't necessarily have anything to do
with what the federal reserve's mandate
is so we go and we actually look at the
four things that the federal reserve is
supposed to be focused on has nothing to
do with eliminating climate risk and has
nothing to do with advancing racial or
economic justice now you can argue that
there could be the impact of these
things but that is not ultimately the
mandate that we've given them one of the
questions could be maybe we should
change the federal reserve's mandate
that could be up for debate and if the
uh our elected officials and others in
appointed positions desire to change the
mandate of the federal reserve to
include these things that would be a
whole different conversation but as it
stands today the federal reserve is not
mandated with doing any of these things
instead it is focused on the four things
that we just described so if we go at
the bottom here there's one other
sentence i want to read which says to
move forward with a whole of government
approach that eliminates climate risk
while making our financial system safer
we need a chair who is committed to
these objectives and we urge the biden
administration to use the opportunity to
appoint a new federal reserve chair
now
there is the mention right there of the
financial system safer but
the idea that the federal reserve is
going to eliminate climate risk or
advance racial and economic justice does
not really coincide with the current
mandate so it brings up the question of
should we change the mandate or should
we simply say hey we have to
govern or we have to judge the success
of the federal reserve based on the four
criteria the four areas of focus now
there could be a strong argument to be
made that one of the things that the
government is supposed to be focused on
or the federal reserve is supposed to be
focused on is stable prices well we
don't have stable prices in america we
have cpi of over five percent so if we
don't have stable prices you could argue
that they are not doing a good job of
meeting that mandate the second thing is
that they're supposed to be full
employment they're supposed to pursue
that full employment and again
employment has gotten better over the
last few months but we still don't have
full employment and so you could again
argue that they're not doing a good job
with that mandate so there's plenty of
what i would consider healthy and
accurate critiques of the work that's
being done but i don't think that it is
fair to say that the federal reserve is
not focused on eliminating climate risk
or advancing racial and economic justice
because that is not their mandate it
would be like going into a high school
classroom in a math class and saying hey
you didn't answer any of the history
questions the kid would say yeah cause
i'm in math class right i'm focused on
math you're judging me on my math skills
you're not focused and judging me on my
history skills and so i think that we
have to be very very careful here that
we don't allow uh conversation
in social media from politicians et
cetera to start to actually shape
monetary policy right or to shape the
federal reserve and what i mean by that
is one of the key components of a
central bank that makes it effective is
that it is independent it actually is
not subject to the whims of the
political environment nor of individual
politicians that was true of the
republicans when president trump uh was
in office it's also true of these
politicians right it doesn't matter
which side of the aisle it doesn't
matter what their agenda is the central
bank should be independent of that
political environment and so i think
that this is uh pretty eye-opening in
terms of reminding ourselves what are
the mandates of the federal reserve they
don't include these things around
climate risk and racial economic justice
and so if we would like them to now have
that mandate we can go and try to add
that but i don't think that you can
actually ask for the non-reappointment
of chairman jerome powell
based on this criteria there's plenty of
other arguments you can make that i
think would be much better received than
making these hey guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today and don't forget to check out
our partner sofi they make all this
possible they're a super app that lets
you save spend borrow earn and invest
all from one single platform and if you
go there today and you sign up for a
sofi invest account you can get between
five dollars and a thousand bucks for
free from sofi not everyone's obviously
gonna get a thousand dollars but
everyone gets something don't say that i
never did anything for you go check them
out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]
you